joe biden spoke of america being at a
point of inflection
and here in the georgia town of stone
mountain they know what he means
these quiet streets were the scene last
year of angry protests
the backdrop was the town's
controversial history carvings on the
mountain of confederate generals
this was once the place where the ku
klux klan lingered
here sweat at the local martial arts
club
instructor walter maddox is relieved
that all that is behind them
he hopes his focus is his business
and the new president he says has
delivered he's stepping into a lot of
things there was a lot of turmoil
there's a lot of
tragedy and i think if in time things
will heal and things will will
definitely get better
we just got to be patient and just give
them a chance to work it out
it was the one-off federal government
payment of 1400.
part of the multi-trillion dollar rescue
plan which saved him
money straight into your bank account
straight to my bank account didn't have
to look for it or whatever
georgia is the state which propelled joe
biden to the white house
republican for nearly two decades it
flipped blue in november
and critically gave him the senate too
and the power he hopes to push through
so many far-reaching policies
manuels is an atlanta institution it was
jimmy carter's local
clinton and obama popped in too
[Music]
but the regulars are ordinary folk who
came to watch the speech to congress
i mean i know he's coming on in years
but at the same time
he has the ability to reach across the
aisle and get things done
young republicans like adam keller say
the biden policies are proof
of his far-left agenda it's an advantage
he says for the return of trump
now you have an administration where
he's saying that he's centrist but his
actions and his policies are so far left
and when the middle see that they are
not really sure where
to go so part of our agenda that we need
to really get across as far as
republicans go
we need to find the middle again outside
the state capital
a hint of one of the nationwide
challenges
we're definitely still polarized fallon
mcclure is a local attorney
and democratic activist i think there's
a portion of this country that
um votes against their best interest
and i think as we move along and you
know we have more jobs and
the economy rebounds i
kind of think they'll have no choice to
be like oh this isn't so bad right
maybe everyone having health care and
you know not going broke
you know because of hospital bills or
paying exorbitant amounts for insulin
maybe that's not such a bad thing
if america is as president biden insists
moving once again
well it feels still to be in two very
different directions
mark stone sky news in georgia